- You never wrote a song for Leslie.
So now you have, right?
And you're wanting to serenade her, right?
- Well here's the thing.
Our anniversary is today
but we really can't go anywhere
or I can't buy her a present
because we're isolated in the house.
So what I did is, I tried to write a song.
And someone is gonna
hand it to you right now.
- Oh, okay.
- And I would like
you to sign it to Leslie.
- Oh, you would like me to sing it?
- Yeah this is a tribute to Leslie
and our 23 year marriage sung by you
and how good you do this will determine
if she thinks if it was a good present.
- Also, the lyrics might determine
(laughing) if it's a good song.
- I think it's all in the performance.
I mean, the lyrics are fine
but I feel like you have
to give it your all.
I need some vocal gymnastics.
- Okay.
- I need you to really
bring your A game to this
or I'm gonna get in trouble
quite honestly.
- Fine.
Fine.
- Okay, here we go.
Let's do it.
- I beat her really bad at a game,
I can at least serenade her.
(chuckling)
Okay.
- I need full commitment,
let's go, full commitment.
- Okay, full.
♪ 23 years for 23 years ♪
♪ You have been in my heart ♪
♪ For 23 years ♪
♪ We never been apart ♪
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, keep going.
Keep going with the gymnastics.
- Okay, okay.
♪ For 23 years I been the luckiest man ♪
♪ On the face of the world ♪
Usually one would say planet, it's fine.
- Oh, oh sorry, sorry.
(laughing)
♪ In 23 years we still be together baby ♪
I added a baby, my bad.
- I like that.
That's fine, that works.
- I'm like one of those actors
you hate to work with that improvs.
(laughing)
- No, I like the improv.
That was good.
Go with it, keep going.
- Okay, okay.
♪ In 23 years I just want 23 more ♪
♪ 23 years 23 years ♪
♪ 23 years ♪
- More of that, more of that.
Wait-wait, more, more.
- More, oh.
- More of that.
♪ Oh yeah yeah 23 years ♪
- Higher, higher, higher
- Oh yeah
♪ Oh yeah yeah 23 years ♪
(laughing)
- You broke the microphone.
I love you, Leslie.
I love you.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry, Leslie.
But that's amazing.
Congratulations.
- Thank you, thank you.
We'll do well.
For her it's a big
congratulations for tolerating,
tolerating me.
(laughing)
It was harder for her.
It was easy for me.
- No, y'all are like a
magical couple to watch.
I felt that at "Hollywood Game Night".
Y'all are fun.